no
oh my god we said no at this time but
also
this is a vhs right
vision
is this really happening she's going
crazy yes
the devil's in the details beth that's
not the only place he is
the devil
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars one
division just premiered on disney plus
kicking off marvel's next phase with
two episodes depicting the avengers
scarlet witch envisioned trapped in a
freaky sitcom reality and we gotta react
to
both of these episodes because we have
questions wtf or as we like to say
wanda
[Music]
this is inside marvel new rock stars one
division after show i'm eric boss here
with
fellow marvel nerd and child of tv land
reruns
jessica clemons hey jessica hi i've
switched locations so now i'm in my room
at my actual desk
and i have a spinny chair and i will try
my hardest to stop doing this
but who knows it might add to the
i get it yeah i'm feeling a little uh
shifty right now too i don't know what
we're watching with one of these oh my
god i can't wait to talk about it and
i'm gonna try so hard to not go into
like just like nerd details of just like
how beautiful no
please do but please go as deep into our
details as you want this is new rock
stars that is true
that's what we do here yeah who's
subscribing that's not a nerd
yeah right um a big spoiler warning
before we continue
uh yes the hour is late the episodes
literally just dropped minutes ago but
this show is insane we know a lot of you
marvel fans stayed up
late to watch and you need answers we're
gonna explain what west view is and make
no mistake folks
one division is no comedy it is a horror
and we are gonna explain why and uh yeah
there are easter eggs and clues hidden
all over the damn place i'm gonna break
all those details down shot by shot and
two separate videos
coming out um i think sometime later
today uh
or friday being today and tomorrow
saturday
oh and by the way you can celebrate
marvel's return by checking out our new
latest obsession shirt
inspired by wandavision it's called an
unusual couple i love this shirt it
shows visions floating consciousness and
it has easter eggs that are only
revealed via augmented reality on your
phone
so you gotta move fast though because
these are collectible limited supply
items and after we sell out back in the
blue dungeon they go
uh just find them at
newrockstarsmerch.com and those who get
this vision shirt will
unlock the extra option to write a
custom shout out for these episodes of
inside marvel
all those shout outs are going to be
appearing at the bottom of the screen um
let's see what we got
ricardo thomas hernandez says happy we
get more jessica clemens
on new rockstars because she is a damn
rock star
oh my god sponsor me rockstar
also our friend carol brown says uh this
is a bq for
eric and philip when skynet goes live
will this shirt activate
yeah that's what's crazy about this
unusual couple shirt it does feel like
um very very involved it's very
high-tech it's like now my
t-shirt is talking to my phone what is
worst
dark and strange it's brought to you by
stark industries yeah oh yeah ooh
also epic hero shop launched their own
companion shirt featuring wanda with its
own secret ar component so for all you
lovers out there
if you care about keeping this unusual
couple together jump on that
and a quick reminder that epic hero shop
is doing something amazing they are
giving away
10 ps5s you can enter by subscribing to
their youtube channel
epic hero labs fill out the form that
you find at epiccaroshop.com
giveaway every 10 000 subscribers there
will be a new winner announced and
there's a bunch of ways to get more
entries into that giveaway on that
website so check it out epicheroshop.com
giveaway all right jessica break down
what happened in these first two
episodes of one division
okay so if you know me if you're a very
close friend of mine you know that i
can't summarize because
i get too into details and i need to
explain it
so i'm going to try my damned hardest
for you guys to keep this short and
sweet and to the point so we opened the
first episode with the newlywed couples
coming in in their car playing and this
like quirky clutzy cute couple that they
are
to what i assume correct me if i'm wrong
boss is like i love lucy themed or i
love lucy or
um dick van dyke's show because uh it
seems like that calendar might be
1961 and dick van dyke ran 61-66 i need
to get more into the years okay
so i immediately was like oh i love lucy
i'm into this so either way they're a
newlywed couple
inspired for sure yeah inspire it's yeah
so dick van dyke i love lucy you say
whatever you want to
assume but they're a newlywed couple
coming into their new home and they're
being so cute and quirky
we have elizabeth olsen wanna maximoff
cleaning dishes making everything
levitate
right when the vision just walks through
and breaks one with his face they see a
heart on the calendar that says august
23rd
and they go to the conclusion that maybe
it could be their anniversary but no one
really knows but they refuse to
acknowledge
that they both don't know so they go and
on with their lives being like
maybe it's our anniversary i think it is
uh vision has to hide his persona so he
shakes a face onto his face he turns
into paul bettany
which i'm so mad they didn't acknowledge
and say like he just turns into paul
bettany i'm sure paul bettany was
thrilled
yeah he was like oh god this makeup has
left
my freaking face we're introduced to
agnes then right after
um the neighbor to uh what does she say
she says i'm your neighbor on the right
my right not yours in a very cute quirky
matter we love catherine han coming in
here
she has so many questions immediately
about like what are you doing alone
who's your partner
where's your children what's your life
like and through those drawn out
conclusions they come to the idea that
maybe tonight is their anniversary and
agnes starts to help her plan for the
occasion
then we cut to vision at work at a
computational forum place that we don't
really know
and he works very well because guess
what he's a robot and he's doing all
this computing
when we are then introduced to his boss
mr hart we come to the conclusion that
that tonight is the night that they have
a dinner with his boss mr hart who's
wanting to meet vision and want to max
him off
so he's like oh i need to call my wife i
need to call wanda
we get this cute phone line conversation
of like they're just not understanding
at all where they are vision still knows
that it's the dinner
wanda still thinks it's the anniversary
hilarity ensues they go into it
immediately
with mr and mrs hart coming to dinner
wanda
showing up in a white nightgown all sexy
thinking it's the anniversary klutz idea
i love lucy dick van dyke see it's not
at all what it is supposed to be
so through a series of 50 slapstick
comedy they come up with breakfast for
dinner
that's when we're introduced to the
horror of the first episode they're
berating them with questions of like
why'd you get here where did you come
from it's like get out scene really
and we get kitty whose real name isn't
kitty i call her kitty from that 70s
show because she's the mom
starts asking these questions on repeat
almost like she's about to cry
you don't know if she's a part of sword
you don't know what what's happening but
it's a very awkward scene
where wanda calmly tells vision to help
her bo his boss mr hart who's choking on
the dinner he gets his powers takes it
out
they call it end they leave abruptly
after choking and then at the end of the
scene
they talk about how much they love each
other and it zooms out with a vignette
over the shoulder shot of sword working
on a notepad watching on a tv screen
the show that we just watched it's dark
and seedy
and
no it's it's such a like crazy idea like
this is such a classic setup for
like these old-school sitcoms like the
boss is coming home from dinner you
better impress them and the
the wife misinterprets it and then
there's like this kind of like
oh wait i miss i didn't know that's what
you meant and then it's
can we say jessica this show is horny as
you like when you talk about being
tongue-tied and she's like
this after all this time it's like
children are watching that
you put that in the notes and i when oh
my vision was like what are you
wearing what are you wearing i was like
damn i was like damn they're about to
have sex
that was like this is like you know
those old school shows were super horny
too like
you go back and watch it's like did the
censors know what the writers were
joking at
it was it also has so it's so
cute and so perfect and katherine han is
everything that i look to be in a con
like a comedian actress she plays that
trope
so well like it's inside she's laughing
i'm obsessing over katherine han i feel
like
everything she says has a double meaning
and i i rewatched you know and i'm like
wait so what did she really mean by that
i i'm losing my mind it didn't say also
the guy with the mustache if anyone can
tell me who that man
is he is so funny he's the guy that's
like cleaning out his desk in the first
episode
that's just like yeah phil jones is the
character's name
i'm obsessed with him he has a lot of
good one-line jokes
and i'm like damn this is a guy oh his
name is uh david langell
david i haven't seen him in other stuff
before but that guy is
freaking hilarious he's got some of the
best ones he's got the best one-liners
which i want to talk about with the
second episode
so because the second episode has his
best one-liner either way so the second
episode enters with what we talked about
in our first preview of the show
that was on the jimmy kimmel show when
we heard the bump in the night turns out
to be a tree branch
and when i said i bet my mom's life on
it being someone walking into a wall hey
i take it back
well it wasn't that but i don't think
it's just a tree branch right there it
was probably some of this uh the
beekeeper or the helicopter or something
so it's the bump in the night episode
where she makes the beds turn into
one king-sized bed and then they
canoodle into the night
we wake up they're so horny so this is
uh the bewitched
we re-watched it and we thought dream of
a genie but they obviously didn't give
any like
shout outs to dream of genie but i
thought it was i dream of jeannie but it
is the bewitch kind of
sort of years and we're getting that
like she's obviously a witch let's see
what's gonna happen
um they're getting ready for this magic
talent show that they're doing for their
town it's for the children it's an
elementary
school fundraiser and they always say
for the children
i immediately was like this is weird
as well yeah wanda the
what for the where's the children what
children are y'all talking about
so they're getting ready for they're
getting ready for that magic show with
vision and wanda
performing their trick and wanda
reassuring vision that she wants to be
normal this is their new town now
uh vision's like you're right so he
embarks to go find the neighborhood
watch to make sure that the
neighborhood watch is up to snuff with
security which
they never are so wanda here's another
danishes yeah yeah oh of the stuff with
eating danishes
so wanda hears another crash and goes
outside and that's where we see the heli
the red helicopter from the trailers
it's in the front
bush she's looking at it very pencilly
like she's staring at it
concentrated to me it felt like a little
bit of her color was coming back
slightly but i think i was just going
crazy insane with like
trying to be you and be like where is
the eye where is it
so of course it was already like she was
shook and awake by agnes screaming hey
and showing off her rabbit for the
talent show mr
and you're scratchy soon you're scratchy
thank you sorry
oh did he say the rabbit is mephisto
yeah the rabbit is obviously
the the rabbit has to be messed up but
not gonna be the fifth stone so
they basically go meet up with dottie
and the part the party planning
committee and reassure her that dottie
is the only person she's the god of the
planning committee
when they go to um and they go to uh
what i assume is a country club
and they repeat again as a unit this
time this is for the children and is of
the utmost importance
that's where we get all these one-liners
from agnes that are very funny but also
too telling we're also revealed to find
out that one of the women
in the group is monica so
it might not be but she introduces
herself as geraldine but
from us breaking down everything we know
it's monica rambo but either way yeah it
sounds like a name she just made up on
the fly yeah she also sounded really she
stuttered when
she paused and said uh geraldine and so
we're introduced to geraldine in that
moment we cut immediately
to the neighborhood watch that's in the
library and basically the neighborhood
watchmen
hated vision before they didn't trust
him before but now since he's loosened
up they think he's really funny
they're all quirky and great and they
offer him big red gum where she chews
and immediately
becomes drunk because it gunks up his
wires
and that's how vision's body works
sure it comes off his it gums up his
gears and that's how his body works
we're then taken back to the country
club where wanda is cleaning up for the
committee
she's talking to dottie about their
relationship when the static that we saw
on the trailer starts happening through
the radio it's
it's playing like the beach boys but we
also see the static we also hear wanda
where are you what's going on she's
starting to like come to consciousness
while dottie's like
who are you what is that she's about to
cry and then the radio come bust
the lemonade daddy's holding breaks in
her hand shatters revealing red blood
and wand is just like what the hell just
happened and that is like
they leave it at that and they go on
living their lives before the talent
show vision appears drunk
obviously hilarity ensues when vision
appears to be so drunk that he's just
gonna
reveal his powers to everybody but
luckily wanda counteracts it with her
vision with her powers
citing that it's illusions it's
illusions illusion so the neighborhood
doesn't think
they're weird and at the end of the
night they get awarded like the best
hilarity the best great part for the
fundraiser which is really good
and then wanda reminds vision this is
for the children
gets up and reveals that she is pregnant
and we're like oh my god
the children are her babies are her
twins when another bump in the night
goes out they go out to go see what it
is
and that's when we get the scene from
the trailer of a man climbing out of a
manhole in the middle of the night no
one around
in a beekeeper suit surrounded by bees
and he turns and looks at wanda where
wanda goes
no and we get a rewind an old school vhs
rewind
back to rwanda says we're doing this for
the children
or i it honestly stunned me so hard at
that scene that i was like
what happened they kiss we get color to
the screen we get color to the room
they recognize that vision turn magenta
again that everything's coming back to
life
and then we get that static from the
radio and it ends and i
need to talk about the second episode
yeah that
was wild and let's not forget these
commercials that they
plug in the middle of the episodes that
if you need more marvel easter eggs
they got uh a stark uh industries
toaster
the toast uh mate 2000. they have the
highest
watch the strucker watch like
what is the line for you yeah he'll make
time for the two
accessories a man needs his lady and a
watch
and i got a i got a name drop here that
guy was if maria enriquez uh he was on
my
house improv team at i o he's a really
funny guy
he was part of this so i screamed that
far when i saw him
uh yeah and another buddy of ours eric
delgado who went to
college with me and philip was the tap
dancer in an episode so it's like i
know people in the show this is so weird
how do i get on the show
wait a minute yeah i know i feel like
we're one step removed now
i'm so mad now wait a minute i want to
tap dance all right but what's our big
wtf
for this okay first off there's too many
uh what the [ __ ] is westview and when
are we yeah okay
so westview west view is the name of the
sitcom town it's a pocket reality that
wanda and vision appear to be trapped in
everyone in it appears to be under a
kind of spell
they sort of play along to these sitcom
tropes but sometimes they
wake up for a moment and suspect that
something is wrong and kind of turn
against each other
but then they kind of go back into it so
obviously if you're watching west view
is a kind of
illusion because uh vision is dead he
died in infinity war the version of
vision we're seeing
is not the real vision um this is all
taking place after avengers end game
though within the bubble according to
that calendar
episode 1 appears to be set in august
and the re the way we got that is
there's only certain years where the
month of august
begins on a tuesday uh there's like the
year 1950
but then on that calendar it says all
this little girl wants is a color tv and
color tvs were not invented till 53 and
we're not in american homes until the
60s
so this would have been 61. dick van
dyke is kind of the more the reference
point but episode 2 is set in the late
60s
with the bewitched so based off of that
trajectory we can probably assume
episode three will be set in the 70s
episode for the 80s with the family ties
stuff episode 5 maybe the 90s one with
roseanne episode six
i'm guessing 2000s with uh modern family
and
we know that because paul bettany
himself said that episode 789 will be
kind of the final act of the season
all will be revealed and the finale of
this season will be kind of an avengers
style showdown so that kind of gives you
the road map for what we can expect
so again west view uh this is actually
whatever it is it's located in the
middle of this random wooded
area and it's being closely monitored by
sword s-w-o-r-d
sentient world observation response
department uh marvel fans know that in
the comics sword is an offshoot of
shield
it's focused on extraterrestrial threats
they have this like
space station orbiting earth that people
think in that post credits even far from
home that that's where nick fury was
uh it's called the peak but in this show
sword includes jimmy wu you know that
was randall park from ant-man the wasp
darcy lewis from the thor movies and
monica rambo
we talked about her she is grown up from
when we saw her captain marvel she's
gonna be in captain marvel too
so yeah this is like a simulated reality
kind of like things you've seen in
x-files the matrix truman show twilight
zone
uh actually like there are specific
there's an episode kill switch of the
x-files that features a simulated
reality that uses
its twilight time uh as the early one
division trailer did
uh and also there's that episode of the
twilight zone one of my favorite
episodes it's a good life
with uh anthony like oh very good
anthony the mind control boy
oh okay and they're all just terrified
he turns one of them into a
jack-in-the-box
but it doesn't seem like this outside
authority of sword
is the one imprisoning wanda there she's
kind of in control of it
it makes it seem like the illusion is
coming from within
yeah the illusion is coming from inside
the house oh my god it's coming from
inside the house
i definitely like got that that was the
episode one where they ended with the
sword
like writing down well okay so this is
where i'm a little confused which maybe
you can clear up
so we get the end of episode one with
sword like writing down something
closing it obviously watching on a
monitor what's happening or
replaying this for her maybe she's
unconscious and sword is like this is
the only way to keep her kind of tamed
but then we have the jimmy wu voice
coming through the intercom
being like who's doing this to you so
that's where i'm like yeah
maybe sword is watching over this
unconscious body
while she makes these things in her head
and maybe we're seeing what's just
playing in her head while on the outside
it's actually just
true turmoil it's just like the world is
like a
chaos it that might be the case we know
from trailers that there's appears to be
some kind of uh
perimeter fence around like an actual
piece of real estate
uh that seems to be part of being this
warping thing so either wanda is in the
middle of it she could be somewhere else
uh doing this but it seems like she's
trapped in it and that voice over the
radio asked who is doing this to
you yeah you know so it's it makes it
sound like wanda's not even fully in
control of it they recognize that she's
not
at fault she's kind of a victim yeah um
there was this moment where the
beekeeper comes out
with the sword logo on his suit yeah and
wanda says
no and things rewind like the videotape
so she has some control over what's
happening
but i don't think she's fully aware of
it i don't think she's playing coy
i think she's going in and out of full
consciousness
yeah clearly there's some other unknown
entity trapping wanda in this spell
and sword is just trying to help end it
and break her out of it
i think she wants to stay she wants to
stay in it clearly because she was like
no
i love this world that and she's trying
so hard to be like
we need to fit in we need this is our
home now and also when we got
west view i think it was in the
beginning of the first episode the west
view sign says like
home is where you want yeah and then it
says home is where you make it
i think too so literally it's like she
truly is just like
i want this is our home now i want us to
be normal i lived a life as just like
my brother's dead and the world outside
of this is so dangerous like
i think she just truly is like this is
our i want to be as normal
as a family can be by being these
sitcoms
and we know wanda has reality warping
powers in the comics we haven't really
seen that
in the mcu yet but this is what it looks
like she can change the reality around
her
but it appears that someone else is kind
of hijacking her so i think that's the
real question we got to ask it's not
just what is westview or when is west
view but
who is this mysterious third-party
hijacking why does reality warping mined
to create this illusion um so
just to run down a couple of candidates
uh it could be catherine han's character
agnes we've theorized that her name
could have come from agatha hartness
which uh the that is the witch companion
to want to maximoff in the marvel comics
who turns against her agnes is clearly
up to something but we'll talk
more about on that in a bit yeah um it
could be the demonic entity agatha
famously serves mephisto
who famously in the comics has tried to
trick wanda with the illusion of her
children
or the children in order to drain her
chaos magic
or the children more about pistol later
or the children and if we interpret this
pocket reality as a dream
this could be another marvel entity
nightmare from the dream dimension he's
a foe to doctor strange whose sequel
wanda is confirmed to return in next
year yeah those are some candidates it
might be someone else i think some of
these answers will come up in the name
west view itself jessica because we've
also heard there's another part of this
town east view and i've speculated that
could parallel the wicked witch of the
east the wicked witch of the west
and the wizard of oz something we know
this series seems to be hinting at with
the trailer footage showing
the movie theater marquee playing oz the
great and powerful yeah
absolutely also wouldn't it be fun if
their
like sons went to like i was i was
reading so many things i was like yeah
this is like a basic family what school
does the kids go to
where does the children like what school
is it and if it's east view and what
their mascot would look like this is
just a weird side note that i'm like i
can't wait to see her go to a football
game
cheering the kids on uh and speed has to
like uh
not use his power yeah it's literally
the incredibles where he has to slow
down so i'm sorry
speed up speed up speed up yeah it's uh
i think
the for the children is kind of the clue
we need to take away from these first
two episodes like
where are the children like all these
people are doing everything for their
kids
i don't see any kids around like that's
obviously the joke with wanda having the
baby bump at the end but
do these other families have kids where
are they on a saturday afternoon
where they can just leave them all alone
i can't wait to see that babies
i can't wait to see them babies we're
going to go more into all this first we
want to thank some friends who helped us
make this episode
our friends it keeps thanks to keith's
response for this episode as guys so
much of our identity i guess is wrapped
in our hair
right from how it feels after getting a
fresh cut to the way it's perfectly
styled before going out that's why when
you start noticing the first signs of
hair loss
for a lot of guys it feels like panic
time thankfully now there's keeps the
simple and easy way to
keep your hair two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have some hair left keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved hair loss products
out there now you may have tried them
before but probably
never for this price you used to have to
go to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit the doctor
online and get a hair loss medication
delivered right to your home
they make it easy and deliver the
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and
awkward doctor visits so if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to keeps.com
wandavision to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash one division also we want
to thank expressvpn for sponsoring this
episode
we all know how a vpn protects your
privacy and security online
now you can also use a vpn to unlock
movies and shows that are only available
in other countries
use expressvpn to binge doctor who or
star trek discovery on the uk netflix
all you gotta do fire up the expressvpn
app change your location to the uk
refresh netflix and that is it
expressvpn hides your ip address and
lets you control where you want sites to
think you're located
choose from over 100 different countries
that's a lot of netflix libraries
if you love anime you can use expressvpn
to access japanese netflix
and be spirited away expressvpn works
with any streaming service hulu bbci
player youtube you name it there are
hundreds of vpns out there but the
reason i use expressvpn to watch shows
is it is ridiculously fast there is
never any buffering or lag you can
stream in hd no problem expressvpn is
compatible with your phone media console
smart tvs and other devices you can
watch on the go or on the big screen
wherever you are
if you visit my special link right now
expressvpn.com
one division you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free support
the show watch what you want and protect
yourself at
expressvpn.com one division and finally
thanks to our friends at manskate for
sponsoring this episode the best and
mints below the waste grooming
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels
they obsess over technology developments
to provide you
the best tools for your grooming
experience now i don't think vision has
any body hair
but maybe he does when he's in dick van
dyke or
danny tanner mode those men were
famously furry
famously furry if that synthesizoid has
pubes you know he would want the most
advanced
possible tech to trim them something
like the lawnmower 3.0
the manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting their lawnmower 3.0
their third
generation trimmer features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to
advanced skin safe technology the
battery will last up to 90 minutes and
the whole thing is waterproof it's even
got this cool led light to illuminate
grooming areas for a closer more precise
trimming it literally shines for the sun
don't experience it firsthand for
yourself and trim that junk of yours
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code onedivision at manscape.com that's
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code wandavision
and for all the uh women watching our
shows maybe
we'll have some sponsors that you can
find interesting
me even you even me
all right let's move on to some more
questions that we had from this episode
wtf uh is agnes deal
uh also her husband ralph isn't real
right okay those are in your notes
and ralph is real but you can you go
first you think ralph is real i don't
think ralph is real
ralph is okay okay okay all of
all of the jokes agnes makes about ralph
are
so good the disappearing act where she
was just like
can you make ralph disappear i was just
like
ralph has to be mafesto i think they're
like hinting at the fact that okay
i know that i'm like yeah the rabbit's
mufesto ralph's from the festival but i
think it's true
i think how can he be watching wanda
without watching wanda
he in the comic books doesn't have that
much power because of wanda taking it
so it's just like what if he is like
doing as much as he can
to get in that world and like mess with
her with the
like the least amount of magic that he
can use and it's like by putting himself
in the form of all these things
so i think we will get ralph soon and it
will just be like
mafesto but not like he's not going to
come out as a mafesto he's just going to
look like a normal man
but i think like that's a great theory
something
is going on with ralph and i think that
is now my favorite theory of
what is going on with this guy because
either he doesn't exist or he is someone
else because the way she says it
is like um my husband ralph
right that we all know i have a husband
like she's either lying and she has
murdered her husband
and he is like uh a rotting corpse in a
rocking chair in her attic
or he is mephisto or both if you
break apart ralph it spells mafesto um
i'm trying to connect any dot i can um
yeah uh devil ralph ralph is the devil
like he's gonna be famous
um ralph lauren the polo shirt
um no i think obviously agnes no
agnes is my favorite character to watch
right now i feel like every word out of
her mouth like every gesture
feels motivated and it feels deceitful
in some way
like she had this whole dinner ready to
go i know that's kind of an
ethel joke from like i love lucy uh
towards just this crazy neighbor who's
super nosy
and always trying to poke her head in
the door she always comes in the back
that bewitched intro she was coming in
through the door whereas everyone else
was outside
like uh the fact that she has this
rabbit the fact that like
it was interesting during the magic show
she like grabbed her purse as if she was
gonna pull a gun out and just start
firing
like something when she threatened the
mailman triggered when she
when the mailman walked by mailman right
it was two pew pew pew pew
it was too like uh wild to put in there
without something mean
without a meaning something and so i
think maybe the mailman was like from
sword
and he got in and she's just like you
keep starting problems
yeah like because he was like don't
shoot me i'm just the messenger like
what if he's mephisto okay i'm sorry i
am i understand that i am
turning into voss now it's rubbing off
on me but hear me out
don't shoot the messenger what if he's
the messenger delivering news
to agnes being like do this next i i
don't
i don't know maybe maybe i think agnes
is going to be
the um the direct villain as this series
goes on
um katherine hahn is like a fairly big
name and she's so good
but i think you know there's going to be
a hint later in the series that she
has she serves a greater master and if
that's it our memphis that's all we
you need yeah and then it turns out to
be nightmare she's like working for a
nightmare we're like
and then i will trash i will break this
microphone john do you hear me i will
throw it out the window
throw it to the post so what's our
what's our next question
wtf what is going on with the beekeeper
and why did wanda say no and rewind away
from him yeah
so this beekeeper has the sword logo on
the back
is he part of sword uh like all these
other
clues that she's finding a sword um or
is it like
something is that the third party entity
that is now just dressed as a sword
beekeeper or something like that
so two things when i first saw that
beekeeper i said maybe it's swarm
one of the worst villains in marvel
history
uh but don't laugh at me why does
everybody laugh at me when i bring this
up to people i'm tired of people
laughing maybe it's warm maybe we're
just getting ready i don't know
i i don't know maybe he's coming out of
the woodwork made of bees he's made of
me
my notes literally said uh beekeeper
equals swarm a body a man of bees
like it's so stupid but secondly i was
zooming in on that man's face in the
beekeeper suit
and it kind of looked like paul bettany
um please correct me if i'm completely
wrong but i i was like this could be
like
yeah swords trying to break in deeper in
her mind trying to get her out
but what what do the bees mean what do
the bees mean what do the bees mean
bees berries i'm working on a theory
that will probably end up in a breakdown
and everyone will yell at me but like
there's hexagons in this folks and i
know hexagons are just like a natural
uh geometric shape that you know fit
together
in cool patterns and so you see that
texture everywhere
but like in both episode one and episode
two the wipe that they use at the end of
the episode is a honeycomb style hexagon
at the bewitched intro there are six
stars around
the moon that forms the six points of a
hexagon
is there a beehive conceit that they're
working on and that's what the beekeeper
is connected to
i'm totally reaching i know i know maybe
it's like yeah
maybe it's uh it's uh what is it called
when spies it's a honey trap
or a honey honey or a honey pot yeah
maybe it's a honey trap it could be i
mean
look it's i just think it's weird that
um they changed so much stylistically
between episode one and episode two
they're completely different sitcom
formats very different humor tones even
uh and the fact that they would keep
that hexagonal wipe at the end is weird
it means that some
designer is like no we want to keep
hexagons as part of this
that's true and it's definitely not
swarm but it's something
it might be yeah that's i didn't think
about that at all i'm going to think
about that now
also get in the comments either this
beekeeper is either someone from sword
who's trying to get in
and she doesn't want sword to end this
kind of
dream reality because she kind of likes
it uh or
this is some other entity because that
entity was scary the way he turned that
was pure horror
well does she have any kind of sort of
um uh
because when we saw in the second
episode we saw the watch and it had like
hydra
i was like oh maybe she's getting
flashbacks so does the
does it bees i'm trying to think of the
bees have anything to do with her like
past before she was an avenger and i i
mean the only thing i think of his
ultron and his drones right
ultron had drones uh that you know once
you took out the queen bee of ultron all
the drones went down
that's true okay this is a good i'm
gonna keep on i don't know
i'm gonna keep on this hopefully we get
another beekeeper scene okay wtf
is going on with the neighbors herb mr
and mrs hart dottie phil
norm beth et cetera how in on it are
they
yeah right these other town residents um
i don't know if they're more or the
question is are they as in on it as
agnes is uh are they all
like is it kind of a conspiracy is it
like that um
that twilight zone episode where it's a
good life where they're all just kind of
terrified and playing along
obviously dottie isn't afraid to call
out wanda
she doesn't trust her um here's what i
think uh
i think some of the people in the town
are just
average people who are being hypnotized
or brainwashed to play along with this
i think agnes has her own agenda uh
and she's kind of playing it with them
uh
and i think monica rambo might have her
own agenda just because i
i know she's a sword agent i don't know
of all of these people mr mrs hart
phil norm beth herb i don't know if
they're all sword agents
um but i think they uh are
aware on some level that this is false
and they're kind of trapped i just like
i i don't know who they are i don't know
if they're real or if they're like
actual people just were in the wrong
place at the wrong time when wanda's um
hallucination began and they just got
assimilated into it
that'd be interesting i feel like it's
hard because i was like oh you have to
go all in or nothing so i feel like all
of them have to be like him
um like have to be controlled by mafesto
but then also
it's like was mafesto or whoever is
controlling wanda even if it is just
wanda
was she expecting to be in that world by
herself
so i feel like they had to have just
some of those people are not sword
agents aren't people that were in the
vicinity are people that are made up
because i was like how so was the
original plan just to put
wanda in there by herself and to be
happy
so i think only some are sword agents
and some are like families in that
wooded area that got
pushed into that but i'm trying to more
figure out who i think the ones
are so like mr and miss dottie i think
are people created
i don't think they're sword agents i
don't think they're people that were in
the vicinity
i think they're created and they were
probably on just a loop that got like
messed with because wanda was coming to
the realization maybe when she starts
coming to the realization of things
those people that are
around her are people that were created
like dottie
actually maybe not like donnie because
dotty asked like who are you
what's going on yeah i think they're all
um normal people
who are under a spell because the spell
kind of wears off sometimes uh mystery
missile started there's even a moment
where mrs hart was like
my head is spinning and deborah joe rupp
was she did such a good job
switching back and forth to when she's
in sitcom mode and in that moment it
felt so sincere where she's like no
everyone we need to stop the take
that's what it felt like um of course
daddy when she's calling him out um
phil when he's like oh i'm uh whatever
that moment where he calls norma
communist and norm's just like
what like that scene i was like oh my
god
that was so funny what was dude dear
lord
vision there are some theories out there
that herb could be
like his name's herbert and he could be
herbert wyndham which we have a theory
for guardians of galaxy vol 3 that he's
a high evolutionary
i don't know if this guy will play him
i'd love for this guy to play i think
this guy's great
i want to see him all these uh
background actors are fantastic
i want them to be regular key players in
the mcu
they are so good they're so good and i
love that
and to use them to their full capacity
they're in every episode just playing a
different character
and i'm so proud of them for i'm so
happy that disney was like oh we're
going to keep with these same people
we're not going to like
different world different people i was
like this is so good they're so good
but yeah maybe they are maybe they are
just like all controlled by bethesda and
brought in randomly
and i would be down for that i don't
know mr mrs heart are not
i feel like they're part of it yeah i
think they're all to an extent part of
it i just don't know if they're
real uh people or if they're just
projections the way vision is
and if what we're seeing a vision is
based on some kind of corporeal
um uh like base you know that they
dragon vision scorps as we talked about
and then from that corpse like maybe all
these people
maybe here's here it is west view's on a
graveyard
and all of these people are the souls of
people
resurrected from the graves below and
that
wanna has projected this town of west
view
so it's pet cemetery but
hear me out stephen king get on this um
marvel meets pet cemetery uh i really
hope it's not
oh yeah i hope it's not too that'd be
real weird but i do want a zombie marvel
universe so let's
go ahead let's get on that wtf is the
weird way for the
chant or the children what one
that's something right i think this is
the whole point of this feels like to
get wanda pregnant and have her have
these kids yeah that's what
they're like for the children because we
don't see other kids and maybe see other
kids in the background i don't think we
do
i need to go re-watch but the fact that
these two babies
the whole town is obsessed with like
getting them to this point where they
just
rapidly progress through their lives and
have kids
that's why it has to be mafesto because
i'm just i keep being like
we're just pressuring these children to
come to birth so he can reabsorb them
so he can take them back and so it's
less like what what other reason but
also let's like jump ahead to the
trailers where we saw the halloween up
like the halloween bits where we do see
children in the background we see
children everywhere
that's right we see those children
because we are given the actual children
or well not the actual children but
the children that wand is about to have
maybe like once wanda has children then
they're like
oh computer this is we should make other
children now we know what other children
look like
um right but it's like so children come
eventually
right they do but based on these two
episodes when they say for the children
i think it's just for wanda's children
and that's it
uh it's scary that there's no other kids
here so
it's such a horror show it's such a poor
and that's why i think i love it so much
because i'm like this is terrifying
this is not a sitcom this is um this is
like an adult swim kind of thing this
feels like too many cooks
a little yeah like everyone's just kind
of playing along and smiling but they're
about to get stabbed
here it comes and she cuts her hand and
shatters her and shatters it and then
her line after she shatters that glass
is straight up like
pop quiz how does a white how oh why a
white house how does
how does a housewife get blood out of
like linen and she was like she does it
herself i was like what
what the hell does that mean yeah and
then she walks away i said the
wanda the you better go fix that
whatever that was
and she never got to talk division about
it which pisses me off you know what
scares me
is it's like is that woman being abused
like
what do you mean why does she have
experience with blood on white linen and
then she has to like clean it up herself
so no one knows like
that's freaking scary what is going on
there phil jones you
uh unemployed jerk what are you doing to
her
take it back um she dottie was also like
just so terrifying
but yeah i guess everything is for their
children i just don't know like what the
hell is the point of the fundraiser
what's the money for the jewelry right
the children the children and how is
that if i guess they sold seats
it just feels like a poorly designed
fundraiser that
we all do a talent show yeah and just
for the children
they also don't really care because when
that like that when she showed the
mirrors
the woman was like is that how mirrors
work shut up beth what's up i love that
line yes
i was like yes we're not going to like
hanging the lantern thing in the script
where they're just like how will wanda
justify
this one it's just a mirror
she said shut up beth that was my
grandmother's piano
uh that was so funny i rewound it i said
okay
i said this man gets the academy award
yes
so the weird way they chant for the
children we it's just
it's just weird it's a horror show yeah
uh wtf is sword's
mission what the hell is doing right now
what are they doing it's hard to say
we're clearly at least monitoring
um they are trying to break through and
reach out to
wanda um that helicopter
has a sword logo on it and we've
theorized before that it might be a
life-size helicopter that went
that got sucked in through the the
membrane
of this town and got turned into like a
toy kind of like
in that twilight zone episode where the
threatening thing was turned into a
jack-in-the-box
uh and the way that um thanos used the
reality stone
also red tinted and warped uh drax into
children's blocks you know
yeah so that um i feel like it's all
connected there
sword uh it's weird that they're having
sword being the one to monitor it
because they're sentient world
observation response department they're
supposed to be
focused on aliens extraterrestrial
threats they did have the first line of
the series is
wanda and your flying saucers which is
you know it's a pun because literally
it's a saucer dish
but like is that a nod to
extraterrestrial threats
and that's why sword is on this they're
kind of like the fbi x-files division
and they are in charge of like this is
another world another dimension and it
is sentient that so we have to break
wanda out of it
i think 100 that's why they're doing it
also it's it's crossing the line where
they're like
they're like the world's like this is
out of our hands because she's opening
dimensions a different freaking like a
universe that we don't know anything
about
so it's like who gets that call not
ghostbusters um so it's sword
it's not ghostbusters but sword so i
feel like sword has to look after it
also she could be opening dimensions to
like
aliens coming through like the alien to
us or
demons coming through or demons
yeah i think uh swords right now they
seem a threatening in the way that
shield in the first iron man movie
seemed a little threatening or
suspicious
but i think sword is gonna be the new
shield of the mcu they're going to be
like
the multiverse version of shield yeah
absolutely 100
yeah and they're going to be good guys
and they're going to be the basis of the
secret invasion nick fury series
these are the guys are just going to
show up in the background uh you have
the tva
as like the time variance authority
who's kind of governing different
timelines yeah
sword is just there to protect earth
from all these different things
100 and i do think like right now all
week
like i agree with you what we can pull
from this is sword is definitely
monitoring her
right now and trying to get in but we
just
i don't think it's a negative thing i
think they're trying to help
obviously i don't think they're really
guys we're gonna make this worse you
know what
let's throw another person in let's
throw another dead body
they throw another one
let's just throw tony if that ends up
being it like all these things are
corpses just a pile of corpses when the
illusion comes down
you bury those corpses you you can dig a
hole quicker than any of us put them
back in there
[Music]
um
oh my god all right we're in a dark
place
let's close out this episode with
another segment of what the devil
what the game uh in which we're gonna
check in to see if any of our insane
theories about mephisto the devil figure
of marvel comics showing up in the
series turned out
any actual evidence or sightings and
folks i think we got at least
one uh at that plan i mean in episode
two dottie says
the devil is in the details and then
agnes mutters to wanda
that's not the only place he is
holy [ __ ] now she could be talking about
the booze she's about to pour
into her afternoon drink but we don't
see the booze in that shot i think it's
deliberately meant to just be a little
wink that
yeah she could also be talking [ __ ]
about dottie dottie's kind of uh
she's a demon the way she's she's
i think that's a tip of the hat toward
like the devil is everywhere
we're only in the second episode so
they're not going to immediately reveal
that it's mafesto but i think like
they have to give some sort of nod and
that is the nod
yeah um you mentioned ralph
i think there is a huge mystery with
ralph i'm not uh prepared to say i think
either
both of us i think he just posed
questions about agnes herself like
agnes has some secret agenda that ralph
is connected to it
i'm i'm almost ready to commit to ralph
being mephisto
but can't wait to the episode where
ralph is at the bar
with vision and he's just like why are
you
here and he's confused at why vision's
here and that is when we're gonna get
the reveal of like
vision wasn't made by him vision didn't
show up
on his own wanda made him up um can't
wait for that scene because it's gonna
happen 90 sitcoms love a bar scene with
two dads
yeah another possible mephisto related
thing that stark toaster in the
commercial this was like the first
truly creepy moment of the series where
it's just that red light
is blinking uh and then my buddy ismar
is talking about
burning from both sides heat from both
sides
like there feels something hellish
related to that it was super creepy at
the very least
what more is hell than two burning ends
and
red dots flashing let's be honest yeah
being trapped in a hot hot place with
just this flashing red
when you were like the creepy red light
i was like yeah but wanda's red
and like they kind of like keep hinting
the blood is red
um but then it's like yeah probably the
best i
this poor podcast people are like this
they've said manifesto 18 times yeah
turn this into a drinking game have fun
you guys are gonna be the uh hey
something to point out about both those
commercials
they both sped up right so like the
toaster went beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep
beep beep striker's watch
so there's something about these maybe
it's wanda it's her unconsciousness
because we were seeing in the
sword looking at they could see the like
her monitor levels maybe that's like a
piece of her like consciousness being
like
you're a human alive you're just
dreaming nightmare
okay sorry no we could be talk and you
mentioned
all the other sightings of the color red
like this is some schindler's list
yeah it is honestly it's the girl with
the red dress so
we'll see if all these color red things
are all kind of connected i think these
all kind of represent
uh the wanda's illusion showing it seems
you know like these are things that
break the black and white illusion when
it's still black and white obviously
we're going into technicolor now so
we'll see
but i think a splash of red is going to
be significant when we look back on this
series
i'm not prepared to say if it's
mephistic because as you said scarlett
witch's color
is bright red vision is bright red so it
could just be connected to her sorcery
uh but mephisto is also a very red
person i think they're just gonna put
all the rest
they are teasing us how can they ah
it's so frustrating what else is right
what are you gonna do all right well
that is it for this first episode of
inside marvel our wanda
vision after show um uh the next video
in the channel is going to be my
shot by shot breakdown of this episode
because there's so many like little
details
that they hid in there i can't wait to
rewatch it uh and then our
breakdown of episode 2 will come out um
tomorrow i think
and then yeah we'll be back next week
with our reaction to episode
three and every friday until the series
is done and we have all of our answers
jessica i'm so glad we're on this
journey together i
i feel like we can speak to some of the
insane
conspiracy theories that others can't i
am an insane person
and like you guys could see in this
episode me piecing things together by
being like
nightmare wait it could be oh swarm wait
a minute what like
i'm made of too much information
follow me at eavos on social media
follow jessica
luluclemens on instagram and twitter um
follow new rockstars at new rockstars be
sure to subscribe
to both our youtube channel and the
inside marvel podcast feed
uh and check out our merch store
directorsmerch.com be sure to get your
hands on that unusual couple
vision shirt it's so so cool and we're
gonna close out with
the biggest laugh we had this episode
that was my grandmother's piano
[Music]
you